[Applause]
[Music]
it is apple season and I am so excited
because in front of me are all of the
new iPhones all of the new Apple watches
and of course our new airpods Pro 2. now
what I'm most excited about of course
because well you know I do love a good
iPhone we have four of them in front of
us we have the new iPhone 14 the iPhone
14 plus the iPhone 14 pro and the iPhone
14 pro Max now this is the new purple
absolutely stunning I'm so excited about
it like the thing that I love so much
about it is it's one of those things
like when you look at the color and as
you move it around it kind of changes in
the light the purple is surprisingly so
beautiful and Tim Cook today had on a
beautiful purple shirt to match the
thing that you'll notice though in the
Pro and the regular iPhone 14 is they
still do have the notch but the pros are
the ones that have the upgraded Dynamic
Island and why they call it this is
because while it looks like that's just
a normal cutout they've turned this into
a feature so when we open up some music
and we swipe up
to play it
you'll notice that it pops up here and
it's interactive so when we start the
timer and we close that that also pops
up there in our Dynamic Island and we
can long press
to bring them up
and to close so it's kind of like
another little notification Hub which is
kind of cool so here are some of the new
colors this is the space block we've got
the purple and this is the light kind of
purplish color which is very faint but
it's really really pretty I do also
really like this blue they look so nice
the iPhone 14 comes in two sizes the 6.1
inch and the new 6.7 inch plus model it
has an xdr 1200 nits double ceramic
Shield display 12 megapixel front-facing
camera with 49 improved low light with
the same a15 Bionic chip that was in the
iPhone 13 Pros but with new thermal
improvements you're basically getting an
upgraded iPhone 13 and a 14 body without
a telephoto lens but with all the new
crash detection and emergency Satellite
Communication features both the 14s and
the 14 Pros have the ability to shoot an
action stabilization mode for super
smooth gimbal-like video the iPhone 14s
will start at 7.99 with the plus option
starting at 8.99
this is the pro Max and this is the pro
and this is the new deep purple color
I'm actually really surprised how much I
love this color it's like a perfect
complement to all of the past colors
like the blue and the green I'm still
hoping one day they'll make a hot pink
Tim come on let's do it anyway let's
take a closer look
the Pro Models have a new brighter
display up to 2 000 nits which is twice
as much as before it features the a16
bionic chip upgraded larger camera
sensor that shoots 48 megapixel photos
it has a 4K cinematic mode and all of
the same new satellite and crash
detection features as the 14. the
dynamic island is also only available on
the pros while the iPhone 14 still has
the notch-like cutout as before you will
also have the ability to shoot a new 2x
mode adding to the 0.5 1 and 3 times
telephoto the pros are starting at 9.99
with up to one terabyte of storage
[Music]
I love the new purple color this is
definitely the one that I'm going to
order or wait am I going to order the
gold again because the gold it's just
it's my aesthetic but also the purple
it's really pretty
this is what I need the Apple watch
Ultra because I feel like I've just
summited
some sort of mountain I don't know
those steps are aggressive
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
have a bunch more videos for you guys to
check out I will put them here in the
end card and also in the description if
you guys haven't already be sure to
subscribe and make sure you hit the Bell
so you'll be notified when I post new
videos and leave me a comment and let me
know what your favorite thing is that
Apple has announced so far I'll see you
guys in the next one bye
[Music]
thank you